the PA Cinquecento was an automotive
legend when it was brought back in 2007
following the revival of other retro
legends like the beetle and the mini all
now fixtures on Europe's roads deaf yet
for car Chester Android cinnamon
describes the new Fiat 500 as the
quintessential success story with some
one and a half million sales it's the
second biggest seller among subcompact
city cars in Germany and the number one
seller in all of Europe now fiat has
thoroughly upgraded it about half of the
Fiat 500s buyers up for the basic engine
combined with the top-of-the-line
equipment option known as the lounge at
115 grams of co2 per kilometer the 1.2
liter engine still emits more co2 than
the stronger twin air engines in Germany
the starting price where our test car is
fourteen thousand six hundred fifty
euros with no extras
westman been few Andre likes the Fiat
500 compared to other sub compacts
because of the well-balanced steering he
says it's noticeably tighter but the
city button loosens it up a bit without
it becoming ridiculously squishy easy
maneuverability is one of the main
selling points of sub compacts as
they're generally used for driving
around town what's really and truly knew
about the new Fiat 500
binary corners Eva Vagner a Fiat says
that they had to be very very careful
with such an icon the risk of somehow
ruining the design was enormous so they
concentrated on stressing precisely
those elements that make the 500 one of
a kind no man is already one of those
features is nicknamed the moustache the
chrome that runs between the Fiat logo
and the headlights the LED daytime
running lights are designed in the style
of the 500s logo a choice of no less
than 10 different light alloy rims helps
to personalize the new 500 one of the
most conspicuous changes is the
taillight inlay and the body's paint the
satnavs displays a bit on the small side
but it has options for example enabling
the driver to stream music from the
internet in conjunction with a
smartphone
and state-of-the-art instruments are
presented in the classic look the
full-size lockable glove compartment is
also new
Dana Andre likes the Fiat 500s retro
chic interior but he doesn't like the
seat height he's quite tall so even at
the lowest setting feels a little
squeezed in shorter people could go for
it though the topic so again Andre
doesn't seem any real changes to the new
Fiat 500 but the touch-ups to the
exterior do make it more stylish unique
selling point among sub compacts is yet
to come a diesel engine